also in our backwards up topsy-turvy
upside down through the looking-glass
world there is a case I mentioned a
little bit yesterday this is one of the
most important court cases that we're
seeing in the next few months you're
gonna see two very important court cases
on transgenderism now who cares about
transgenderism it affects virtually
statistically zero people in the country
but the left has made it a big issue
because the left is using this to get
through their entire agenda the left is
using this to get through their entire
ideology because if the left can force
you to believe that men are women and
women are men then there is no objective
reality there is no objective standard
that we have to refer to it's all merely
subjective preference it's all merely
interest and the left can rewrite they
can rewrite the whole country they can
rewrite our laws and they're trying to
do that right now
so there's this case in Connecticut the
ADF filed a suit the ADF is the Alliance
defending freedom great organization
they filed a suit in February against
the Connecticut Interscholastic Athletic
Conference on behalf of three girls
Selina Sewell Alana Smith and Chelsea
Mitchell these three girls are runners
in their school sports and what they're
suing over is that these girls are being
forced to compete against boys so title
nine of the you know title nine exists
to create female sports so the women can
compete against the women and the men
can compete against the men the women
don't have to compete against the men
because men are physically stronger than
women and when men compete against women
and sports men win there are many
stories on this topic which maybe maybe
will try to go into a little bit later
but generally speaking virtually all the
time men win title nine sets up women's
sports on the basis of sex if sex is
redefined to mean gender if biological
sex is redefined to means subjective
gender identity psychology then if it's
not that that expands women's sports to
include more people that abolish as
women's sports there are no more women's
sports because women's sports all of a
sudden include men and the men win which
is what happened to these girls
and so not only would they lose
unfortunately these tournaments but you
know you could lose scholarships you
could lose college recruiting so that's
the case and the deck is already stacked
against them it's a case they haven't
even gone going through the case yet and
the District Judge a Clinton appointee
by robberies names Robert Chetan Yee
chastised the ADF for referring to the
boys as boys he said at the beginning of
the case he said you can't refer to the
boys as boys this is exact quote what
I'm saying is you must refer to them as
transgender females rather than as males
again that's the more accurate
terminology yeah okay and I think that
it fully protects your clients
legitimate interests referring to these
individuals as transgender females is
consistent with science capital s I
don't know what science he's looking at
but if science means leftist ideology
then I guess it is consistent certainly
not consistent with objective reality
common practice and perhaps human
decency to refer to the boys as males
period is not accurate certainly not as
accurate and I think it's needlessly
provocative I don't think that you
surrender any legitimate interest or
position if you refer to them as
transgender females that is what the
case is about this isn't a case
involving males who have decided that
they want to run in girls events yes it
is that's exactly what the case is about
this is a case about girls who say that
transgender girls should not be allowed
to run in girls events there's no such
thing as transgender girls there's only
boys so going forward we will not refer
to the proposed intervenors as males
understood and obviously the lawyer for
ATF says that's the whole game that's
the whole case if we refer to these boys
as girls as you judge or telling us to
do then we have no case because girls
are allowed to compete against girls
that's what title 9 does our problem is
that you and the sickos and the cynics
who are pushing this ridiculous leftist
ideology are not permitting girls to
compete against girls you're forcing
girls to compete against boys which
totally takes away the rights of
in title nine that's the argument
maybe my version was a little more
colorful but that's the argument that
Roger Brooks the late attorney for ATF
made they finally got the judge to agree
to just use the term transgender so they
say he's a transgender oh I guess they
can't say he the person is a transgender
or a tree but there is no third category
of transgender there are boys and there
are girls and there is a very infinitely
infinitesimally small number of people
who are what it was called intersex or
hermaphroditic where there's some
ambiguity as to the genitals or the
biological sex but of course the
existence of a that very small section
an exception of people doesn't
obliterate the categories right just
when there is sometimes a very rare
ambiguity between two distinct
categories that doesn't obliterate the
existence of those categories and that's
not what's at issue by the way in this
case it's not somebody with an ambiguous
sex it's a boy who by all markers of
objective reality is a boy simply saying
through sheer tyranny of will that he is
a girl and has the right to beat girls
and races and take away their
scholarships that's what's at issue
so even giving up even you know I guess
a DF kind of had to give it up the judge
was just not going along with it
but even giving him that term
transgender is giving away the game this
is the way that the culture is stacked
against the Conservatives this is the
way that science is abused and
appropriated and monopolized and
perverted and transformed to invert
objective reality the judge did finally
follow up he said if you feel strongly
that you and your client have a right to
refer to these individuals as males
could you imagine calling boys males and
that you therefore do not want to comply
with my order then that's unfortunate
but I'll give you some time to think
about it and you can let me know if it's
a problem if it is gosh maybe we'll need
to do something I don't want to bully
you I don't want to bully you like the
torturers in 1984 I don't want to force
you to say the two plus two equals five
but you know you have to say it or or
else but I don't want
bully you because I want to believe you
but at the same time I don't want you to
be bullying someone else you know by
calling a boy a boy and a girl a girl
and saying two plus two equals four
maybe you might need to take an
application to the court of appeals I
don't know but I certainly don't want to
put civility at risk in this case it is
you judge who's being uncivil it is you
you are you're the uncivil one because
you won't use common language basic
language objectively true symbols to
refer to reality because of your own
ideology because you are so blinded by
your ideology which you call science
which the left has always called it's
ideology science they've called it the
science of history since Karl Marx
you're so blinded by that ideology that
you actually believe that a boy is a
girl not very scientific to me if that's
science perhaps we need some other basis
of knowledge with which to understand
the world with which to argue and with
which to form our policies
[Music]